we had major news over the weekend with
regards to Donald Trump's
muslim-majority country immigration ban
there has been an order from a judge in
Washington that has suspended all
aspects of Trump's immigration ban to
remember to to sort of revisit the
original stipulations of the ban Donald
Trump's executive order bars citizens of
seven Muslim majority countries from
entering the u.s. for 90 days it stops
all refugees for a hundred and twenty
days and it indefinitely halts refugees
from Syria a judge has put a stop to it
Judge James Robart who was appointed by
none other than Republican George W Bush
in 2004 has put a stop to it and as a
result all actions related to Donald
Trump's travel ban for people coming
from these seven muslim-majority nations
have been suspended by the Department of
Homeland Security period as a result of
the judge's order a quote from the
acting press secretary of the Department
of Homeland Security Gillian Kristensen
in accordance with the judge's ruling
DHS has suspended any and all actions
implementing the affected sections of
the executive order entitled protecting
the nation from foreign terrorists entry
into the United States this includes
actions to suspend passenger system
rules that flag travelers from
operational action subject to the
executive order in other words all
day-to-day DHS activity is going back to
what it was before Donald Trump's
executive order the executive order
currently dead the State Department has
been reversing the visa cancellations
that had taken place as a result of the
order u.s. Homeland Security employees
have been told by their department to
start complying with the ruling
immediately customs officials told
airlines they can resume boarding banned
travelers this applies to Qatar Airways
Air France
Etihad Lufthansa others saying if we're
gonna go right ahead and do that Donald
Trump and his cronies have attempted not
to defend the legality of the ban but
rather just to slam judge Robards ruling
and Jane
slam him personally not only was this
the decision of Judge Robart it was
appealed and a federal appeals court
also rejected and said no we are
sticking with Judge Robards decision
that the suspended state of the travel
ban remains there have been two states
that challenged the travel ban and the
way that the Trump Justice Department
attempted to push back against this was
saying hey states just don't have the
authority to challenge presidential
executive orders judge Robart decided
that indeed that is not the case so what
happens now we have seen one Appeal
upheld the next appeal if upheld would
make it so that it could get all the way
up to the Supreme Court and this is
obviously the right decision but we have
to be really careful I suggested last
week that part of what may be going on
here and I don't for a second think
Donald Trump is smart enough to actually
do this but maybe Steve Bannon isn't as
we know Steve Bannon increasingly in
control of what's going on in the White
House there may be a strategy here of
these major shock events that have huge
repercussions judge orders of ACLU
getting involved massive protests and
then the Trump administration may modify
the original executive order with
something slightly less crazy which may
be what they actually wanted all along
and because the big headlines will be
that the original order was not allowed
many people may just forget about it and
stop pushing back and might actually
allow what is truly the Trump agenda to
go forward so we have to pay attention
to that there's another really important
story implicit here which is that if
this case now goes to the Ninth Circuit
and is upheld and is then appealed to
the Supreme Court remember that until
and if Neil Gorsuch is confirmed the
Supreme Court is split for four
ideologically having only eight justices
instead of the normal nine
in all likelihood the Ninth Circuit
decision is the decision that will stay
and since it is very likely that the
Supreme Court could be deadlocked what's
missing in all of this is the effect on
the people there's this sort of
cartoonish version of immigration that
people in that some people in the US
have and I can assure you that as
someone who left my country of origin
and came to the US this is no small
thing
this is life-altering for the people
that are actually coming to the United
States either as immigrants or with
refugee status and playing politics with
it the way that Donald Trump and his
administration has been doing it it
really ignores that these are people's
lives who are either way going to have
their lives irreversibly changed either
by coming to the US or by being blocked
from coming to the US by an executive
order so this is absolutely the right
decision I am NOT going to stop paying
attention to this because for now it is
suspended if you were hiring you
probably have figured out that posting
your job listing in one place isn't
really enough to find quality candidates
you really need to be posting on all the
top job sites and now you can with one
click through zip recruiter which also
has 9 million resumes in their system
already which you can search through
doing targeted searches to look for the
perfect candidate for your job you can
post your job with zip recruiter com to
100-plus job sites including social
media networks like Facebook and Twitter
with one click sort of like a search
engine for finding and posting jobs you
can find candidates in any city in any
industry all across the country you post
once the qualified candidates start
rolling in two zip recruiters easy to
use interface and one of the greatest
things about it is the interface makes
it so you don't have to juggle emails or
calls to the office you and your entire
hiring team can screen candidates rate
candidates and ultimately hire the best
person quickly using the zip recruiter
interface and dashboard and if you have
any issues
there's friendly human support staff
ready to help you can right now post
jobs on zip recruiter for free by going
to zip recruiter dot-com slash free
trial my listeners can post jobs unzip
recruiter for free but you have to know
where to go and that's zip recruiter
dot-com forward slash free trial one
more time try it free zip recruiter
dot-com sacha free trial